now I'd like to introduce you to our
speakers today our first speaker is Eric
Jacques Faye who is the Leicester Levi
Carter professor and department chair of
chemical engineering at Stanford
University here in 2b SC summa laude
from Princeton University and an MS and
PhD from Stanford University all in
chemical engineering he joined the
Stanford Chemical Engineering faculty in
early 1990 and in 2001 he received a
dual appointment and became professor of
mechanical engineering he is most
recently a faculty member in the
Institute of computational and
mathematical engineering at Stanford he
has authored or co-authored over 180
publications and has been an associate
editor of the physics of fluid since
2006 Chuck Fay has been awarded the APS
Francois and Frankel or the NSF
presidential Young Investigator award
the David and Lucile Packard fellowship
in science and engineering among many
others he is a fellow of the American
Physical Society and a member of the
National Academy of Engineering
Lisa Wang is a senior lecturer in the
chemical engineering department and his
co academic director of the Stanford
Chemical Engineering online master's
degree program she received her BS in
chemical engineering from MIT and her MS
and PhD in chemical engineering from
Stanford working with the Curt Frank
group on polymer thin films and
interfaces she has served as a lecturer
consultant for the office of the vice
provost for teaching and learning it is
the faculty director of ta training for
the chemical engineering department she
has been teaching in the department
since 2006
Elizabeth sat Lee is an insistent
professor in the Department of Chemical
Engineering at Stanford and a Stanford
chem age faculty fellow she also serves
as an honorary adjunct staff scientist
at the Carnegie Institution of science
dr. sat Lee completed her graduate
training at Boston College in organic
chemistry and her postdoctoral studies
in biochemistry at Harvard Medical
School where she worked on natural
product biosynthesis and bacteria
inspired by human reliance on plants and
plant derived molecules for food and
medicine thus at Lee laboratories
focused on the discovery and engineering
of plant metabolic pathways to make
molecules that can enhance human and
plant health work in the South Lee lab
has been recognized by an NIH new
innovator award a do e early career
award in h h mi simon's faculty Scholar
Award in an AAAS Mason Award for women
in the
Sciences and finally Alexander Dunne is
an associate professor in the Department
of Chemical Engineering at Stanford
University his research focuses on
understanding how living cells sense
mechanical stimuli with particular
interest in stem cell biology and tissue
engineering dr. Dunn worked as a
postdoctoral postdoctoral scholar with
James Budaj in the Department of
Biochemistry at the Stanford University
School of Medicine he received his PhD
at the California Institute of
Technology under the direction of Harry
gray where's work focused on
understanding the catalytic mechanism
selected CH bond oxidation by cytochrome
p450 enzymes his work hasn't been
recognized with numerous awards and
clean the Hertz fellowship jane coffin
child's postdoctoral fellowship the
Burroughs welcome Career Award at the
scientific interface and NIH directors
new innovator award so an amazing panel
that we have today so now I'd like to
start by turning the floor over to you
Eric and Lisa okay all right today we're
here to discuss the introduction of a
new online master's degree in chemical
engineering and I would like to give you
some history and perspective on how that
came about in our department we've had a
residential master's for many years now
even near the beginning of the
department our department is somewhere
around 50 plus years old but we've all
thought that we're actually missing an
audience with our master's program
particularly the people who were
professionals working at companies that
wanted to get advanced education but
essentially we're working full-time jobs
so we wanted to open the access to this
and we now have a faculty that's of that
size that we can actually do such a
thing so this is the introduction of a
new program we're targeting a new
audience we have our own new admissions
program for that degree and we'd like to
talk to you about some of the specifics
so that we encourage you if you have
this interest to apply to our online
masters degree program now through March
19th for this code ultimately our
program was structured with these two
goals in mind to provide greater access
as
mentioned to a population perhaps we
weren't reaching for before and also
Stanford is an amazing place where you
can structure a degree and giving you
the flexibility to structure that degree
in a way that combines a very in a
nationally top-ranked chemical
engineering institution with the wide
range of engineering coursework that's
offered at Stanford so you can structure
a program within your interest set with
an interest set that perhaps has
interests outside chemical engineering
such as entrepreneurship artificial
intelligence biological studies etc and
still obtain a very first rank online
master's program we structured it to
accomplish these goals in the following
way we're going to ask you to complete
45 academic units all offered by the
online learning 27 units in chemical
engineering eight graduate level courses
and one engineering seminar and those
courses will have in them not just you
folks the online masters folks but also
our PhD students are residential masters
etc and these will be taught by our
regular faculty all of them on a regular
basis we beyond that then we add the
flexibility that you can as I said
structure the program so you can look at
other interests that you might have that
would be supplementary to your interest
in chemical engineering and that means
that you can take 18 units in
engineering science or math electives
200 level classes or above for any of
the online offerings that are presently
offered within Stanford Lisa who's the
director of the program and myself are
going to review your program sheets and
particularly we're going to look at
programs which have three or four
electives in a single topical area again
that's part of our program we want
people to have a to combine the chemical
engineering with an area that they are
interested in and then to our other two
or three other electives that might be
things that they've never taken before
that they have just an interest in again
it's a 45 unit program 27 unit
in chemical engineering and eighteen
units in engineering science or math
electives I'm now going to hand it over
to Lisa and she's going to tell you a
little bit more detail about the program
that we've structured great thanks Eric
so the way our program is structured is
that we ask you to take four core
chemical engineering courses and these
are 300 level courses that you can see
below we are offering five of our core
courses online as you can see or you
would choose four and then we'd also
have you choose four additional
electives within the chemical
engineering graduate programs that we
offer online and these range from you
know anything from heterogeneous
catalysis to entrepreneurship in the
engineering and Sciences I'm so even
within the chemical engineering
requirements you do have some breadth in
terms of the electives and we have as
you can see from our core courses we
really emphasize a molecular engineering
perspective and you will see as it see
this throughout all of their coursework
in the department now regarding your
elective topical areas there are areas
of focus we're really fortunate that
Stanford has a wealth of online graduate
engineering courses that are offered
online every quarter and we encourage
you to take advantage of this so you
know think about what would be most
beneficial for you and your goals for
obtaining this degree you might have a
concentration in entrepreneurship
you know applied math modeling
optimization etc this is really where
you get to tailor the program to meet
your needs sorry go ahead Eric let me
say just a little bit about that as Lisa
is going to show you now on the website
for the program we have taken the time
to actually write down subgroups of
courses which fit underneath these these
areas which you might be interested in
and so therefore we encourage you to go
to the website to go to
viii ptl's description of these courses
so that you get an idea as to what your
program would look like and how it would
fit your interests
great so what we're showing you here is
just two of these sort of pre-selected
courses that we thought would be of
interest to folks for example who are
interested in entrepreneurship you can
see that you know in in addition to the
world class chemical engineering
coursework we are surrounded by great
colleagues who are discussing
entrepreneurship from potentially a
management science and engineering
perspective or you might be interested
in learning about this from a from a
civil and environmental engineering
plants optimization and control again
you have great opportunities to take
advantage of expertise in the air last
your department from you know a ee lens
management science and engineering you
get to craft and tailor your
concentration from the perspective that
you are particularly interested in so
let's um we're gonna seed in some sense
the questions with a couple that we
imagine would be well some of the most
appropriate or interesting to you so
let's start this question about what is
the time of completion again this is in
some sense self-paced we imagine people
taking one or two courses a quarter and
then finishing it finishing the 45 units
if you do take one course a quarter and
you can do the math you can complete
this in about three and a half years but
we imagine some people will take as much
as five years to do it some people might
have the time to do it in a shorter
period of time but but again it's
self-paced and that's part of the
advantage of this program that you can
do it in some sense in your own time the
second question I am interested in PhD
in chemical engineering is this program
right for me if you want to get a PhD in
chemistry you probably don't want to
take this program we have very few of
our residential master's students making
the transition to the ph.d program
because frankly the requirements are
very very different you
this program has a terminal online
master's experience for professionals
who want education in chemical
engineering and then in other related
fields so the short answer is no of
course we will consider an application
in for a PhD in chemical engineering but
it's really not a prep for the PhD it's
a it's a terminal program and then the
third question is I may prefer to attend
classes on campus and so suppose you
want to switch
in fact suppose you want to switch
either direction we've structured the
program such that they are very very
complementary so this would be
relatively simple that is to say if
you're taking the online masters you are
satisfying residential master's
requirements and therefore could make
the switch however we would like to
control the number of people that switch
so we will consider petitions for this
switch and restrict the number per year
Lisa did you have anything I think
Thanks
thanks guys so now I'd like to present
Alex Stein who's going to be our next
speaker I know Alex has a commitment
after this so um I do want to encourage
people that have questions during his
presentation just submit them in the Q&A
box and can ask him before he has to
leave but fun fact about Alex he
recently submitted a paper to the
journal science about a special protein
that gives a self physical structure
that work can ultimately help us think
about regenerative medicine and how we
can engineer human stem cells to form
tissues and organs to replace what's
been lost accident disease he's
exploring some really interesting
questions in his research so it's my
pleasure to hand off to Alex so he can
talk about his work in his upcoming
Spring Quarter course that you can take
with him great well thank you very much
and thank you all for coming to visit
if virtually with us today so I'll begin
by just mentioning in a few minutes my
my research labs interests and that is
really very simple you and I and the
mouse you see on your screen all began
as a relatively undifferentiated mass of
cells and yet we grew into complex and
beautiful organism
and as an engineer this provokes very
simple question how did that happen and
how can we recapitulate that process in
the lab in order to build new
replacement tissues so the goals of my
lab are to understand how biology builds
itself from molecules up and importantly
to understand the physical rules by
which cells work together to construct
living tissues so for example in the
story we published a few years ago we
perform simple experiments on zebrafish
and Rios is their little fish just like
you see in a pet store you learn some
simple rules about how the tissue is
arranged themselves and we're now
applying those rules to try to
understand how groups of stem cells work
together in the lab in order to build a
complex tissue that could be used for
regenerative medicine purposes now as
part of that study we're really
interested in the sensors and actuators
inside every cell in your body so you
can think of these as nanometer sized
strain gauges or even muscles but scale
down to the nanometer length scale
importantly these molecular assemblies
actually perform both mechanical
functions and also compute information
is something I would love to talk about
with you at greater length now in in one
such study we used advanced light
imaging to try to understand how living
cells move through solid tissues and how
they remodel their physical surroundings
what we found is that these cells are
powered I can track tile struts as you
see in this movie where we used advanced
image processing to track the movement
of individual protein complexes within a
living cell and one way to think about
it is that these cells which happen to
be the cells that repair wounds for
instance in your skin actually use the
same design principles in order to
generate force in motion is this sort of
creepy looking cheetah robot that was
created a few years ago my boss
dynamics now we are of course here to
talk about the classes that I teach
there are two classes if time allows
I'll discuss both of them the first
which I'm teaching next quarter is
called chemical kinetics and reaction
engineering and I tell stories in that
class about each of the images you see
on the screen now here's the syllabus
and our approach to this topic is a
little bit different in this department
than in most other departments and
focuses very much on the fundamentals
that drive chemical reactivity so we
start with transition state Theory the
question of how reactions occur and as
I'll show you on the next slide we also
think about the deep connections between
the kinetics of chemical reactions and
basic statistical physics we then move
on to understanding the basic rules that
underlie us modern and predictive
understanding of heterogeneous catalysis
and explore their deep connections with
the same rules that control how
biological enzymes work we then finish
with an introduction to systems biology
and systems of coupled reactions and
transport now this is a practical
example here's the monsanto process
which was used in yet in an industrial
scale to produce acetic acid usually
with it if I memory serves an Iridium
rather than rhodium base catalyst now in
this laboratory study it was discovered
that despite the presence of eight
species and corresponding high number of
reactions the overall rate was dictated
by the concentrations of only two
species by using very simple principles
as possible to determine why that is and
use that information to optimize
reactivity as I mentioned earlier
they're really only a few physical rules
that govern chemical kinetics one of
them is very simple statistics of
improbable events so in the first
lecture of the course I'll explain to
you why
the injuries to soldiers due to poorly
behaved horses in the Prussian army
actually led to the fundamental
mathematical understanding that drives
our understanding of chemical reactions
so for example unlike in most courses on
this topic will actually perform
stochastic reactions that give you
insight into chemical reactivity and
allow you to model systems with small
number of components as would be common
for instance in some Diagnostics
applications the second topic in this
course is why do reactions happen and
what makes them faster slow so here is
just an example slide showing one
fundamental result in the field
transition state theory that relates the
rate of a reaction to a ratio of
partition coefficients Q double dagger
and Q hey this provides deep and
beautiful connections between our
understanding of statistical mechanics
and of chemical reactivity as the course
progresses we move on to more modern
topics I'm particularly enthusiastic
about de novo design of functional
enzymes for both laboratory and
industrial application this is a topic
that I think will have enormous
importance in the coming years now
that's the most relevant and immediate
information I should mention that I also
teach a second online course on
biochemistry that's quite complementary
to the advanced topics taught by my
colleague professor Sally and just like
in kinetics I teach that course around
stories involving all of the things you
see on your screen there now
why study metabolism which is really the
basic concept in this course is human
metabolism well human disease is one
very important and obvious application
perhaps slightly less obvious but still
pretty immediate is the connection to
synthetic biology the rules you'll learn
in this class will allow you to come
strucked in a rational way complex
molecules like the anti malarial
artemisinin and then finally this course
provides foundational knowledge for
understanding how the beautiful natural
world around us works now the underlying
insight in this course is how to go from
complex and information like this
metabolic network I'm showing here two
fundamental insight in other words how
to pack detail into your head in a way
that makes sense and that allows you to
make practical decisions in the future
all right that's all of my questions
that's all of my material I can answer a
few questions if you are interested we
didn't have a question coming for you
Alex so someone asked within your course
do you explore how small chemical
changes impact IPSC s to form teratomas
or how other cell culture errors develop
oh yes indeed we do so for those of you
who may not know those acronyms
that's an induced pluripotent stem cell
which is a powerful substrate for tissue
engineering we're especially interested
in how the interplay between mechanical
cues like tissue geometry or mechanical
forces within the tissue combined with
the biochemical signals of the cell
receives in order to tell the cell live
die divide differentiators stay the same
these are the rules that construct us
and that I think will be incredibly
important to understand for tissue
engineering all right yeah great I I
don't see any other questions coming
through quite yet so if anyone has any
other questions for Alex feel free to to
put them through but if we don't get a
chance to follow up as I know he needs
to go to his other commitment we will
certainly do some follow-up so thank you
so much Alex you know taking the time
today to speak my pleasure and happy to
answer any questions you may have
great all right so now I'm going to move
on to our next speaker
I'd like to hand it over to Beth um a
fun fact about Beth she was recently
named as one of the forty-seven
investigators on the Chan Zuckerberg bio
hub where she will be focusing on
merging engineering and detailed
knowledge of plant biochemical pathways
to enhance human health this bio hub
initiative will invest more than 50
million dollars to support people like
Beth in her life science research so
it's an exciting opportunity to take her
course and to learn from her so now I'll
hand it over to her
thanks Beth great thanks very much
Stephanie for the introduction I want to
start by actually introducing my my lab
and my broader research program where a
collection of engineers and science
scientists who are interested in plants
as plants and what I mean by that is the
ability of green plants to produce
molecules at scale that are critical for
life as we know it so we're fascinated
by the amazing capacity of plants to
take the world's simplest building block
carbon dioxide and produce so many
molecules that are important to us for
example the food we eat these processes
lead to the air we breathe biofuels
we're considering for renewable energy
as well as numerous molecules that are
either used in the clinic or part of our
diet that influence our health and so
plants are already incredibly productive
but we realized that modern tools and
genetic engineering which allow us to
make multiple simultaneous changes in a
complex organisms genome opens the door
for new possibilities so I want to just
introduce three Grand Challenges that
motivate the research in my lab and as
I'll tell you also have motivated some
of the concepts that I go over and the
course I teach biochemical engineering
so these challenges have to do with
altering the metabolism of plants using
these engineering tools so for example
if we have molecules from plants that we
use in the clinic it's critical to know
that many of these compounds are
produced by plants that are difficult to
cultivate or by plant cell culture which
can be an inefficient source of these
molecules and so we'd like to use
engineered metabolism or engineered
biosynthesis to come up with a new way
to manufacture these particular
compounds we're also interested in how
the chemistry of plants influences plant
fitness and furthermore how it could be
engineered to enhance plant fitness so
small molecules plants produce our
for allowing plans to obtain the
nutrients they need to grow and prevent
disease and grow in less desirable areas
for example high salinity or drought and
finally another area in my lab that has
to do with chemistry of plants and human
health has to do with optimizing
nutrition in our diet
so really using a metabolic engineering
approach to make plants healthier and so
again these grand challenges motivate
the work in my group and also how I
approach commends 355 biochemical
engineering so in this course as I'll
tell you my goal is to really present
the tools and concepts that are required
to really build any engineered
biological systems so as I have shown in
the circle that could be an engineered
cell it could be an engineer at higher
organisms such as a plant where we're
going to modify the machinery from DNA
to RNA to protein to either product or
function to obtain new chemical
functionality and so some of these
things you could think about are maybe
ones you've heard before for example the
production of antibiotics in cells or
the production of therapeutic proteins
but there are a lot of new possibilities
as well how could we engineer cells to
produce fuels or plastics or even small
molecules that you don't even find in
nature on the function side again we can
think about using cells as essentially
tools and machines for information
storage cell based therapies and even on
the whole organism scale again for
example nan browning apples is a recent
example from the agriculture side and so
within these challenges comes the
framework for the course objectives and
so my goal is not to have a collection
of students with an expansive knowledge
of biology but to deliver in this course
the basic concepts and the language of
chemical engineering biochemical
engineering that would allow you to
build any engineered system and so at
the end of the course once you finish my
my objective is that any new process
that you hear about either in the news
or a colleague has worked on or
something that's being developed at a
company you understand each of the
components require
to build that system from scratch using
quantitative principles I'd also like to
convey especially towards the second
half of the course ideas about what are
the limits of biochemical engineering
what things
what new tools might we need to develop
and what are the what's on the horizon
and what are some of the frontiers and
challenges in this field and so the
course is really organized into two
parts in the beginning we go through
some of the background on biology that
builds on much of the things that Alex
my colleague talked about in terms of
fundamentals of biological systems what
aspects of a cell do you need to
understand in order to be able to
engineer the chemistry of a cell we do
this in a using a quantitative approach
for example REITs and biological systems
and rates of central dogma that we can
really think about how to apply process
and engineering controls to get the
output that we're interested in in the
second half of the course once we have
this understanding starting from a piece
of DNA going to a cell in an organism
level what are some of the applications
so how might we generate proteins with
new function or metabolic pathways with
a different output and then how do we
think about scaling up and process
considerations for these applications
and so I want to just close with one
example from my lab which is a complex
process and really a challenge that the
principles that you learn in chemical
engineering 355 could help you adjust so
one of the things that we were really
interested in is an anti-cancer agent a
top aside that's used in many clinical
clinically applied chemotherapeutics so
this is a molecule that's currently
produced from a plant a medicinal plant
that's very difficult to cultivate and
in fact that there's there's often
limiting sources of this particular
molecule so in the in recent years
shortages have been reported by the FDA
in part because we have no good way of
manufacturing this drug beyond isolation
from the medicinal plant and so the
challenge for us is could we rebuild
biology could we take that metabolic
pathway from this medicinal plant and
engineer it as a way to produce this
compound and so what we needed to do is
identify
we needed a source for each of these
pieces of DNA needed to control how they
might be expressed in a chassis and we
needed to find ways to keep those genes
and our chassis and and get to the
output of interest and so we've been
able to do this in my lab take the genes
from medicinal plant and transfer them
to much easier to cultivate and grow
plant Nkosi an event Amiata which is a
wild relative of tobacco so thinking
back to a biochemical engineering 355 in
that course we'll learn about all the
steps of a process whether you want to
take the genes from a medicinal plant
and put them into a chassis like tobacco
or you want to build an engineered T
cell or some other process and
engineering great thanks so much Beth so
as a reminder if you have questions for
Beth please submit them into the Q&A box
it's an amazing opportunity to ask her
questions if we don't see any at the
moment which I don't see any specific to
Beth we'll have some time at the end for
the Q&A for her to answer so please
don't be shy about submitting those
questions so next I want to talk a
little bit about online learning at
Stanford so the online learning
experience is a next best thing to being
here on campus at Stanford faculty are
giving lectures that we capture and pose
for our online students they're held in
special classrooms so at the same time
that they're lecturing the on-campus
students they're also capturing their
lectures there are features within the
video player like bookmarking creating
important clips that you want to review
later and notes that you can add to
lecture videos and there are several
ways to interact with the teaching team
such as office hours forums and project
work so here's a great example of what
the video player looks like you can see
Alex Dunn is featured right there in his
bio chemistry 2 class as you can see on
the bottom right you can add bookmarks
and clips by clicking on those icons and
create notes if you need to review a
concept that alex has explained you can
simply watch it again which is really
nice and these lecture videos are
archived and available to students
throughout the quarter so a great
resource for those online learners I
want to talk a little bit about our
enrollment so the enrollment the spring
quarter enrollment period is open now
through March 19th for the graduate
the master's degree program so over a
month still to take advantage of this
deadline
follow these steps starting with the
grad admissions link keep in mind the
GRE is required three letters of
recommendation a statement of purpose
and academic transcripts if you aren't
quite ready to apply to the master's
degree program but you want to get your
feet wet by taking some graduate level
courses for credit you can start as a
non-degree option student with the
Stanford center for professional
development the GRE and letters of rec
are not required as you can see but
transcripts are required you start what
we like to call NGO and NGO application
with us and you can take courses for
credit and apply up to 18 units towards
the master's degree program should you
get accepted so that's really nice so as
we head into the end of our presentation
again we're going to transition into the
Q&A portion of the webinar please be
sure to submit your questions and into
the Q&A box so we can take advantage of
the time we have with these wonderful
presenters today as you submit those
questions I want to remind you here that
the chemical entered the chemical
engineering department is currently
taking applications for this exciting
new online degree program you can learn
more by going to their Chemical
Engineering website and the application
deadline is March 19th
as mentioned before if you want to just
get your feet wet by being a non-degree
option student to start we have two
wonderful chemical engineering graduate
certificates that that you can start
with as mentioned before up to eighteen
units can be applied to master's degree
program this is our biotechnology
graduate certificate that actually
includes kemon ch3 55 with Beth so just
so you're aware of that we also have as
our next certificate the energy
engineering and technologies graduate
certificate and that you can explore as
well that as you're ramping up to apply
for the master's degree program
information on both of these
certificates and the courses that are
involved can be found at SCPD
stanford.edu again I want to make
mention of two amazing courses that Beth
and Alex are teaching this upcoming
spring quarter of course that can inch
3:55 that Beth was talking about
advanced biochemical engineer
and the chemistry 20 chemical kinetics
and reaction engineering so those are
going to be available for those who
apply and are accepted into the master's
degree program and also if you choose to
take it as a non degree option student
and spring enrollment is also open until
March 19th for both for the non degree
option students okay so we're going to
head into the QA we already have some
questions that have come up so let me
just say so
you saw how the exciting wonderful
content of these courses and we focus
this webinar on two vignettes associated
with courses that are actually available
in the spring but in fact similar
stories exist for all of our courses in
energy in catalysis in in solar cell
science etc so it covers the broad range
of what we've tried to do is open this
up to people that may not have the
opportunity to be in residence at
Stanford but still have the opportunity
to have these this really exciting
learning experience that was the
Faculty's vision and goal in this and we
hope you take the chance to take this
opportunity thank you so much Eric all
right so the first question that is
posed to the group and our students in
the online master's program eligible to
participate in the research labs of
professors we don't have a the original
concept was that there would be a
research component to it right now we
don't require it I believe you could
apply to do a research component of that
it's not required in the program right
now and we would consider that but right
now it isn't part of the program it
might be in the future of course that
requires residents usually to do lab
work and so we were trying to divide
those two our master students the
resident online the residential master
students typically do do some aspect of
research as part of their program great
the next question we have is how will
lab activities or hands-on activities be
handled with this online program
yeah as I I think I mentioned there
there are no lab courses that are
included right now in the curriculum if
there are lab modules that are part of
the teaching then they would be handled
online so you would see the lab module
externally but you wouldn't participate
in the hands-on experience ok the next
question is maybe not specific to the
lab but just in general are there
research opportunities for students in
the online program yeah again we have
not required it in the program but we
would accept you could ask to
participate in research opportunities
and we would be willing to consider that
and the faculty would be but we don't
have any requirements for that so in
some sense that would be in addition to
the present requirements no I mean I
think our faculty would be open to you
know interested students just as they
are welcomed our residential master
students have access to the faculty to
explore some options as well so this is
their particularly strong interest I'm
sure you know the student could engage
with the faculty that they're interested
in yeah let's just be clear we we have
students at all levels undergraduate
masters and visiting scholars
participating in research activities and
actually undergraduates from all across
the country and the world participating
in research opportunities within our
Faculty's labs and so that that is
definitely available to you on the
online program we didn't require it
because it requires residents ok the
next question is and we may have
answered this already our online courses
live or pre-recorded I don't know if you
guys have any pre-recorded flipped
situations but I think most of them are
most of them are alive and then recorded
if that's the thing so um I as I think
about it there there might be some if
the Faculty's out of town where he'll
use some pre-recorded classes in those
spots but generally right now they're
live and recorded do you know so most of
the if you're an online student you will
be watching the the video content
asynchronous from the actual class so
the on-campus version of the class
yes but they are live and recorded
someone has asked I'm interested in
polymers I work in the plastics industry
what kind of courses are related to
polymers and are they available yes we
have well let's see online right now uh
I don't believe we are in this academic
year offering our polymers course online
but it is certainly something we could
consider for the future we also have a
variety of material science courses that
go into polymers polymer physics and
polymer applications that might be of
interest that are offered online we have
one sixty two and two sixty two which
will come back next year it's it's
taught this year but not online but it
will come back next year and we can have
it taught online if there's interest
that would be a good thing to do it's
been taught online in the past yes so
another question that has come in
someone asked I have a degree in
industrial engineering I'm currently
working in adhesives industry and my
career path requires for me to
strengthen my chemistry knowledge is
this master's degree right for me it's
it's pretty darn good for you let me put
it that way there's a lot of chemistry
and chemistry related processing that is
in this curriculum much more so than on
the physics side so I would have to say
yes someone asked do I need to enroll in
one of the graduate certificate programs
biotechnology or energy and engineering
or can I take one or more individual
courses related to my area of interest
and I I can answer that question by
saying certainly if people can take
standalone courses they don't need to
enroll in the certificate program in
order to take courses they just need to
meet those prerequisites and but I don't
know if you want to talk to I know
you're involved in in developing those
graduate certificates with the benefits
of taking those right so we we developed
these certificates before we're
developing this online masters and the
express idea now is that if you're
taking those graduate certificates you
can transfer as many of those units over
if you now want to get the online
masters
so we hope that's a very smooth path for
you and and as Stephanie said up to 18
units so that works very very well 18
units is actually I believe slightly
more than any of this or to complete the
certificates so therefore you're in good
shape if you're in a certificate I want
to take the certificate courses and then
ultimately you want to take the online
masters that transition should be
seamless someone has asked I'm a
mechanical engineer is this master's
degree program potentially right for me
yes so we don't so let's say let's put
it this way we don't differentiate in
the application process so we have
applications from chemistry students
mechanical engineers physicists etc now
with that said many of these courses
have prerequisites you've satisfied the
prereq then of course you'd have to take
the lower level courses that are
required as prereqs for these courses
and some of them are online and some of
them are not so it's specific from that
point of view but from our point of view
we don't differentiate so mechanical
engineers I will be part of our program
great so someone has asked it said hello
I'm very interested in this master's
degree program so it's great we already
have some positive feedback I have some
questions but the main one I think is
this do I have to be in the United
States or have studied my bachelor's in
the States to apply well that's
certainly not true because we we admit
PhDs and masters all the time from from
foreign institutions so so the short
answer is absolutely we welcome your
application and it will be considered
just like all of our graduate
applications from from overseas there's
a TOEFL requirement that's in addition
to no and is that the case okay yeah
there's a TOEFL requirement this in
addition to the requirements that you
saw but apart from that it'll be
considered with all the other
um okay I think we're pretty sad with
questions do you guys want to add
anything else before I close I would
just say you know feel free to reach out
to us if you have any questions or would
like to just discuss you know thematic
areas that might be of interest or
anything about the the program we're
happy to answer any questions that you
guys man yeah I hope our email addresses
are available on the website so that
they can send questions online if they
need to
we'll get them answered they may not it
may not be instantaneous but we'll get
them answer right and we fully expect
that questions will come in for the
master's degree program in both the
chemical engineering department and the
Stanford center for professional
development are committed to answering
your questions and making sure to to put
you on the right path should this be
something you want to pursue and again
we're gearing up for this being our
first class by March 19th so please take
a look at all the materials that are
available on the website right okay
great so um I want to just close by
saying you know thank you to Eric Lisa
Bath and Alex know Alex it had to leave
but all for a wonderful presentation
about this new online degree program and
for for answering all the questions that
came through on the Q&A a reminder
application deadline is March 19th
check out the Chemical Engineering
website for more information and
definitely check out we have all the
course pages on our stbb website as well
so please check those out we will be
sending out the recording within a week
to all those who registered for the
webinar and just thank you for taking
the time to attend today we really hope
to see you in the future in this new
exciting chemical engineering online
degree program thank you very much
you